[Music]
hello everyone
this is insane in the endgame with
grandmaster dennis borsch
late night edition so this time we are
going to look at
some tricks and traps in the end games
and some less tricky versions of
the same end games so the first one
is a classical little study
some of you might consider it a little
bit funny
so it is white to move and win and it
won't be
your usual hybrid or build a bridge
and you can't cross it so here
you actually have to use something that
we call
chess magic combinations
so it is white to move and
just sprinkle some joy for everybody
give off already knows everything good
good if you know everything that's what
you need
it is magic time patrick daily it always
magic time
especially if it's end game
so we see a check we
give a check yes so now the king can't
really go there
because you slide over to c8
queen and then you celebrate football
style
so black has to go to e7
can i even make it as
the main move
as i told you guys here the basic
i am going to build a bridge ain't gonna
work
and it ain't going to fly so you've got
to use something
that mihawksaw would call a brilliancy
yep
so let's get into the zone and find the
right way
okay some people want to give a full
rook for free but
is it time to donate yet i don't think
so
at least you have to convince me that
it's time for
some donation if you go rookie to check
i go back and you
ain't crossing this bridge
i don't know about rookie two
indeed so it is actually time to donate
with rook d6
but i mean normally you'd ask why the
rook move
well if like just passes you actually
build a bridge and when you check i can
go rook c6 so if you go back a little
bit
you go king c7 you would get checked
rook d6 king takes d6
and now the king elegantly walks out
just to have a little bit of a sun bath
and after check king d8 and we are
asking who's gonna stop that pawn
now mind you this does not work if
there's no b6 spawn
there would be rook b3 pressing down
that pawn on
b7 and on the b8 square
so it is very important
that there is an extra b-pawn
hiding the b7 one
so you can see that even in end games
there are some tactical ideas that you
can use to win a game
and there's no way of stopping queening
all right and a second note there you
can't really set up this
checkmate because when you go here this
queen's
with a check and it is gg time
meaning the game is over literally
you're going to lose the rook
and then i'm going to face two queens
and in that case you stand
no chance at all good start
good start this is the first thing that
i wanted to show
so i am going to show you another one
between nigel short
and judith polgar we're going to start
from the middle game
but we're going to fast forward into end
game territory
so b takes bishop takes c5 white
has the pressure but it'll only lead to
a rocking game so takes takes rook a8
rook c8 takes op8 okay seven we're not
really interested
in this phase so we're just gonna fast
forward
by the way h4 is a very nice move trying
to
inconvenience that bishop on g6
h5 bishop f3 queen f6 bishop takes h5
takes 6 rook c8 rook takes
take six king g8 and here we're going to
be at a halt for a second
so whenever you get this position you
get your bets
out is this going to be a win for white
or is it going to be a draw
now again don't look at the result
look at the position
first thoughts
draw i hear from ariana
gotla not wrong
not wrong why
why do we think this should be a draw
well it's mostly because the pawn
advantage
is on the same side and it is a
notorious
rocking game so
according to theory this should be a
draw
now g4 is a very nice move by judit
the best female player of all time
you do need to cram down your opponent's
pawns as quickly as possible and you're
going to see the same method
played in other games that i'm going to
show
the c pawn is falling there's no way of
actually defending it
so judith makes sure that she gets
to move forward in that time
rook takes c3 king g2 g6
rook b5 and whenever you get these
theoretical positions it's very
important
to theorize what would be your best
chance
now mind you whenever you get into rook
and games
everybody is low on time and time
trouble
is abundant so you need to find
the best practical try here
best tactic tactical try and best
practical try exactly what i mean is
trying to envision what pawn exchanges
would
actually give hope for a win for white
i see andras scott i'm saying f5
can be played but it's tricky okay
what is the point of pushing the f
pawn what are you trying to achieve
so one of the things that you could do
is push this pawn up
or play h5
passer
but there is one thing that is stronger
than a passer
what is that so actually there's a
choice either you start pushing f4 f5 or
you play h5
well an active king is a good thing but
it ain't better than a passer
a passer is basically our hope to win a
game
the thing that's better than a past pawn
is a protected past pawn
gill knows his end games correct
so if we know that then we can make an
educated guess
which one jude had played in this
position
if we talk so much about a protected
passport
i mean black did play king g7 but
the point is what was judea planning to
do
did she go for f4 f5 or h5
and the answer is f4
f5 if you play h5 you're actually
eliminating one of your potential
passers
and if you take now you do create a
passer but you also create a target
and if you lose that pawn that is 90 a
draw
there's no way you're going to win that
game and with these pawns
being awfully close in that pawn
actually
defending the g6 square this is
very cotton dry and pretty much a draw
however judith is going to go for the
idea of
f4 f5 hoping to create a past pawn
out of the h pawn so let's see what she
does
she plays f3
excuse me and whenever we look at these
games
you might wonder why don't they play f4
f5 immediately
because both of the players are usually
in time trouble by this
phase so it makes sense to
execute a plan in a drawn-out fashion
sort of tiring out the opponent chess
as you might know from the previous
classes by
dorset derek shawnee is part sport
and part psychology here
ethri makes a point of hey i'm in no
hurry
you are here for a long struggle
by the way g5 wouldn't be such a great
idea
because in this sense you would create a
target there
and you will lose the potential idea of
creating a past h pawn
so with f3 juliet polgar is trying to
keep things
flexible rook c4
very nice move by nigel short making
sure
that this king cannot cross the fourth
barrier king g3 rook a4
rook b3 rook c4 and here comes
the time where black is going to go
shuffle back and
forth back and forth but we'll see if
that actually
works out for him
now if we play f4 right here
then nigel short would start giving
checks and
perpetually start attacking those pawns
and in this case you would never be able
to play
f5 that's why jude at first
over defends the third rank and
then starts pushing the f pawn rook b3
look c4 f4 now
so one of the key things to do when
you're attacking and also
sort of defending is to make sure that
your opponent
can't get too active so rook b3 just
make sure that the third rank
is protected okay four
rook f3 preparing this f5 move
rook b4 f5 now
in these technical end games sometimes
you get half a goal accomplished
now f5 ain't winning but it's half a
goal accomplished by judit
and now she is going to have that
passer that she was dreaming of gf
rook takes f5 and voila rook a4
up jumped a little bit f5
rook takes rook a4 h5
and now she has a protected pass pawn so
that is
something to brag about
now a little bit let's try to
think of the defender's side
h5 is menacing but there is another big
threat in this position
what could that be
so why did black go g takes f5 well it's
simple
nigel short felt that the position
should be close to draw in this case
so he felt no reason to avoid it
advancing the king that's one idea
what else could come to mind
g5 indeed if white gets g5
it actually gets a little bit dodgy
because eventually that f
pawn might get under attack and the
closer she gets to that promotion square
the harder it gets to defend so
by that definition we might just know
what nigel played in this position
indeed is the dreaded f6
move but here it makes a lot of sense
you're just
stopping that advance if h6 this is a
complete draw
with the king being in front of the pawn
there's no hope of ever winning this so
obviously
judit is going to avoid that
and also stops these king h4 king g5
ideas as well
rook d5 now rook d5
is these mysterious moves which
you know it's hard to understand
sometimes however
this rook was in the way and probably
what
judith imagined is to bring this king up
to f5
it's kind of tough to do so if the rook
is in the way
so she went rook d5
rook b4 and here comes a probing check
rook d7 check
so chet where would you bring your king
where would you bring your king if
you're faced with this choice
king g9 that's a very safe move
but highly illegal
now if you go king h6 you actually
sort of entrapping your own king
rook f7 and you're forced to go back to
b6
because king g5 loses immediately to
this check
and you lose the pawn
and once you go back i will walk over
to f5 and it's getting very dodgy
so here you had to go king g8 as
alone rook and pawn will not win the
game and the king is
still cut off but judah still tries
plays king h4 sort of preparing some
like h6 king h5
it's more of a ghost threat but a ghost
threat is still a threat
and something that short has to figure
out so if your opponent is trying to
walk
on in this way how can you stop it
snap stop that idea
rogue b1 indeed if they're trying to
walk upstairs you're going to check them
from
behind this is actually a typical
typical way
of defending in these type of positions
king g3 judith says i tried
and short says i know you did
so attempt one
nigel short judith polgar won
zero however the probing
didn't end how else can judah
try to improve on her position
at h6 we talked about that she will play
that but it's not enough
the king is not close enough to help out
with the attack
h6 is by the way very committal when
you're trying to
induce a mistake from your your opponent
you shouldn't be overly committal
in a rocking game because it might just
fizzle out
on the spot
yep so you want to get that king in
so the easiest way is to use your rook
as a shield
remember you're up a pawn so any
exchange would favor you
in fact would provide you a winning
position
so she played king f3 or k4
rook e7 just setting up this idea
so short will have to abundant
this fourth rank king cafe
rook e4 and now a little bit of a
success
by a judit rookie a1
now you can't really go king f4 yet
because you would get these
dreaded checks from behind and you're
back in square one
but judith has something else in mind
rook b4 you can check me if you want to
but then i either go king e4 or king f4
you're not really stopping me
so this is actually a success
by judith she did occupy the fourth rank
so now if you're forced to be a little
bit more defensive
as black what would be
an ideal formation
is it good that this king is on the 8th
is that the ideal place for black's king
now as we talked about it the king does
not want to be on h6 no
so was it fun when the rook was on the
seventh
and i'll tell you what it wasn't
therefore
short says hey i'm going to defend the
7th
get my king to g7 and i'm going to chill
i'm not saying that rookie 1 is
necessarily bad
because that's the other method you
could always
go for these partisan checks and
hope that you can hold that way but
in chess there are multiple ways to
achieve
the same result you can be aggressive
but that you have to be accurate in that
way or you can be defensive
which sometimes takes a little bit less
effort
which might have been preferred because
we are closing
to time control meaning um
the end zone where everyone is running
out of time so rookie 7 is a safe choice
by nigel short
and it is time for us to reap the
benefits
of our plants what did judah play here
yep why not king f4 indeed that's what
she played
king e4 king f4 same old same old
king g7 and now this is again
a grand master move that is overlooked
some of you might just play king f5 here
but then you're facing these checks
but grandmasters know that you're going
to check them
so judah stops you before you could even
dream about that check
rookie for check king f5 row case seven
now short says okay
your king is on f5 your rook is on b5
but what's the big deal obviously g5
does not accomplish anything
because we get into these positions
which is completely drawn
the king is in front of the pawn and you
can never
get on the seventh also every rook
exchange leads to drawn endgame
so she played rook d5
rookie 7.
believe it or not a bad mistake
okay
tactus tactics exactly yep
you're looking for tactics but um
looking forward to a
full solution
indeed age six check and this is kind of
the trick
sometimes you are trying to lull your
opponent's awareness
and lull them to sleep and in this case
with h6 black ran
into this devious little trap by
judit and the rook is not far enough to
check
also it's attacked once you move the
rook
rook h5 checkmate
so the only move here is king f7 it's
not over yet
you still have to be precise as
judith
it's one thing to set up a trick you've
got to
still be resolute
so at the moment we can tell that these
guys are a little bit unfortunately
placed
however our king is prone to checks
that we wouldn't want to see
if you go h7 there's king g7
so it's not that crystal clear
there's a much much more simple move by
judah that
actually wins the game
if you go rook d8 i give a rook e5 check
and you're back to square one and
probably ain't winning
the game either
yep g5 is the big move
by judit making sure that there are no
rookie 5
funny business and the unfortunate
placement of the rook and the king
means that h7 h8 is unstoppable
and nigel short has no way of stopping
that
if the rook was on the side somewhere
else b7
c7 this would still be a complete draw
but as you can see one slip
and a technically drawn end game is
enough
and judet just sweeps
the game rookie one was played
h7 takes check king f4
and nigel short resigned indeed
short's only mistake was rookie 7. his
plan of setting up
the fortress with f6 rook a7 and this
sort of passive or more defensive setup
was completely
fine until rookie 7 which fell
into this nice little tactical idea of
h6 and rook
d8 i mean g5 rook d8
talking about escaping there is
another very famous game
by judith polgar which we're going to
take
a quick look at and it was played
between grishok and
judith so
we are going to start from here this
is still the middle game we're going to
fast
forward to the critical moment also
we're going to
flip the board because we're going to
watch it from
judah's perspective knight e7
take 6 d5
junit was mostly in the back foot in
this game
but as you can see she will be fighting
tooth and nail
to stay afloat take stakes this is still
not what we're looking for here
she is looking for active counterplay
which is very important
knight a7 knight c6 knight e5
here takes
knight e4 king g2 knight f6
here here here king h6 knight e6
and we are going to start from this
position
white is obviously having the upper hand
but that does not mean you can't
continue on
to fight so
you can tell if you're just continuing
with passive defense
it not it's not going to help you out
too
much so how should we continue
as judith
well obviously you should be looking for
active counter play
you should be super aggressive
if they take at least you can go knight
e4 and
hope for some tricks against the king
g7 g6 knight d5
again setting up some trickies
and as you may as well know if you play
chess b4
even in winning positions you can lose
so rook c1 is the only move
because if you go here it is immediately
bye bye
you just lose the game knight e3 check
and the king
cannot really run away so rook c1 is
surprisingly enough is the only move
although obviously it
keeps the advantage rook d2
key one and f5
is taking good we don't really want to
take because
then we would be down two pawns
but actually we will be forced to get
there
rook d1 knight c5 not f6
h3 and so far actually grishchuk
is playing quite well and this position
is objectively
winning f3 rook d4 knight e4
you don't want to get into the end game
because you would be losing
takes takes takes takes and the king
comes in front
and that's a loss
so knight d5 rogue d2 takes z2
knight takes d2 g5 king f2
king f5 and
we are getting into this critical
position king g5
f4 check and this is actually the
critical point
what is the best practical chance
for black in this position
passive defense or active defense
active defense correct
so if we want to be aggressive
that is being active in chess how
should we do that this position
forward king g4
knight e5 check king h3 king f3
and believe it or not in this position
judith found a splendid splendid
idea which actually draws the game
knight g4 which is a fantastic
find by judit and believe it or not you
can't capture because it's a stalemate
and impossible as it may
you can't really win this position
because the g pawn is just too weak
and you will face this perpetual idea of
knight h2 knight g4
and taking on g4 as we already talked
about is taboo
knight d3 that's the way gershouk tried
h2 check king e4
and g4 back so if judith manages to
pick one pawn from grishouk's position
she can just give up the knight on g4
and it's a completely draw position
because
it's a king versus king and a knight and
there's no
material left to win with
knight e5 and how should we continue
here
this is still an important position
if you go knight f2 you might
let this king run
so yes you want a pawn but
you're actually kind of far away with
this knight
probably you can still hold but knight
f2 is a bit too
adventurous not f6
check indeed because if you go here i
can just take on g3
if you capture i take the pawn and as we
all know
this is a draw
so king f3 is forced
and i presume you've seen this position
before
knight g4 again knight g4 is the same
stalemate
so grishook has to come up with a new
plan
knight c4 knight h2 check now if you
keep going back and forth well judith
will go back and forth with knight g4
knight h2
king e4 knight f1 and
that is actually typical of these
knights you are coming closer by going
farther away
f5 would actually run into knight takes
g3
check and i'm picking up the pawn
you have to make a king move and i pick
this pawn
so grishok went knight e3 knight g3 king
e5
king h2 king v6 knight h5
f5 and knight g7 immediately
forces the draw after f6 and
draw was agreed because knight t8 check
is coming
and you lose the f pawn
knight e8 here the draw was agreed but
98 would
be a draw
so as you can see
tactics do work in end games as well
however last but not least i do want to
show you guys
a cappa blanca classic versus yates
where capablanca shows his
beautiful technique now even there
there were some drawing chances for
yates and we're going to take a look
at that one so we're going to start from
this position now it's
four versus three the dreaded position
which is known to be
a draw however it is white to move
which kind of changes things
now if you were black in this position
it was your move
what would you play
h4 okay g4
yes g4 is a very important move
made by the big kappa because if you
just pass
h5 happens and if you cannot create a
passer
as white you're not going to win this
game so g4 is an important move
sort of fixing this pawn on h7
h6 king g3 rook c1
king g2 none in a hurry and that's
actually the way to
play these rook hand games you're never
in a rush rook c4 rogue d5 i think we've
seen this
move before in judea's game versus short
sort of threatening rook d4 chasing this
rook away from the fourth
okay k4 f4 row k2
king g3 rook e5
p1 king f2 and
again in this position we need to
create a passer or slash a target
on h6 how can we do that
how is it possible to achieve that in
this position
yep h4h5 that's actually the big concept
you are going to try to exchange of a
pawn here so you can create a passer
out of the enf pawns also
this guy on h6 can potentially become a
target
king f6 h5
rook e2 check king f3 rook e1
rook a5 king g7
takes king takes g6 and in general
whenever you get this four against three
you would be trying to get a pass pawn
out of the e and f
pawns if it's possible which actually
happened in a similar game between
aronyan
and nakamura but talk about that
another time h6
and that's kind of the reason why yates
doesn't take with the f pawn
because that would mean this e pawn has
a free route
to go to and they might even become
protected
past ones like tanks roaming down the
board
so king takes g6 actually is a logical
e4 okay f1 king g3 check
king h3 and you do not have these
perpetual ideas
because you just don't have enough space
to attack these guys
so then rook f1 rook f5
in no rush first off he is defending
that pawn
and plans to set up a little bit
of an outpost on e5 rookie 1
e5 check king g2 rk3
so far quite a decent defense by yates
this king is cut off and as we all know
it's very difficult to win a rook hand
game or any type of van games with a
king
being far far away from the action
rook f6 king g7 rogue b6
rook e3 rogue b4 again
making sure everything's defended now
f6 which would be a thematic idea to
undermine just
fails to this check and rook b6
and you'd drop a pawn so rook c3
now in this position we need to come
forward with the king
yes king f2 however king f2
is a little bit inaccurate so if you're
defending this position
this might be critical for you
there is one important move that yates
missed
right here
possibly giving him drawing chances
yeah and inside definitely rook e4 might
be a little bit better
h5 yes so if they take the pawn you go
rook h3
and we're going to have a two against
one white has
some chances but objectively is a draw
and if you go g5 you go h4 and
this pawn is just going to be enough of
a nuisance to hold the draw
but yates misses it rook b7
king g8 check again king g7 f5
and with these pawns rolling down the
board
black will have to do something about it
because if you wait around you actually
going to face f6 check
you can't go up there because check and
you lose the pawn on f7
and if you go here e6 and you're
promoting
e6 f takes f7 and it's promoting so
actually
one of the ideas that you have to look
for
is the concept of getting your rook
there get your
e and f pawn on the fifth and threaten
ideas such as f6 and e6
so here yates panicked and started
checking but that only means that the
king is
coming and bolting forwards rk4
king d5 same thing you can't really take
it because you run into this f6 idea
rook a5 king d6 rook a6
king c7 just hiding away from those
checks
and more and more f6 is looming in the
air
note if you go f6 i'm going to play e6
and that is a protected pass pawn
very much likely just to give a win king
h7
king d7 as the king hides away this king
might as well just come and creep closer
to the f pawn
okay seven d6 check i mean king d6
avoiding the check
king g7 rook d8 again using the rook as
a shield
rook a5 but now you get that f6 check in
rook f8 now e6 wouldn't really work
because of this side check
so rook f8 you can go king g6 because of
the aforementioned rook
g8 and rook g7 rook a7
king c6 and slowly but surely
now yates is running out of
oxygen king g6 check rook g7
here now in this position you really
have to be
mindful of a crazy rook but there's that
extra h pawn
which is fixed so you don't have to
really worry about that
that much king b6 rook d7 king c5
sort of triangling closer and e6 is
coming
rook c7 king d6 k7
e6 now check king e7
takes rook e4 and
here comes the final touch that might be
familiar
from a previous game and
that will clinch this match for
capablanca
so try to move and play
e6 was a big move over there
g5 indeed again
you are creating this umbrella idea
you have no more checks and
after you get there you start rolling
with the pawn so either you go there
and then that way or if they go rook e8
you check here
here f7 and you might not even take the
rook because you can promote
to a lady on e8 so after king g6
yates resigned and that kind of
concludes
our session on tricks and traps in end
games
one single trap can win you a game
but don't forget you need to activate
your king
in each and every try thank you for
watching
and good night take
[Music]
you